I am a firm believer that whether you are running a ten-person company...
...or a 50-person, not-for-profit organization,...
...you are only as good as the people who work for you.
What I did at eBay is I had a phrase:...
..."I need the right person in the right job at the right time...
...with the right values and behaviors."
And if you do that, gosh, things are so much easier.
It's curiosity that gets people excited.
Curiosity leads to new ideas.
Curiosity leads to new jobs, new industries,...
...and it perpetuates itself...
...because it's this never-ending cycle of "What if?" and followed by "Why not?"
The hardest thing for me was to learn how to say no...
...and to make some people unhappy.